yeah in a with you in a wheelchair in
five years I'm into longevity drugs
that's my new thing now oh cool cool do
you still have psoriasis I don't oh cool
well wonder what you're gonna get now
just trying some new [ __ ] [ __ ] I'll
put up in cinemate on and I give it I'll
take it I'll take it somebody goes like
this you know Brian I got this new I got
what is it - give it to me
oh don't be a Baba you go like this guy
goes hey I got this new and you up yep
and the guy goes plunk and your body
goes one of those rumors no [ __ ]
whatever yes rice rice tentacles are you
you dude psoriasis remember we were just
talking about that all right what
happened with Brian the guy that we were
just talking to I don't know you
switched your body switch to someone
else that's the only thing that makes
sense how did you get lost in one
sentence man you're gonna be a really
bad father no I'm not do it my kids are
gonna be this [ __ ] bro they're gonna be
like whatever daddy we do not want to
make a mistake help me Amir it was a
math problem all right ready okay huh
what's wrong what's wrong I don't know
why not what is it four times eight what
four times eight well how many times
well you know what eight is yeah all
right what's that twice what's eight
twice you can't eat they have that
feature now but only for their blocker
yes people no no I don't hate people but
you're you'd be good used to this
because when you're you often in a room
with quiet people like your shows that
the Orlando improv yeah and another said
quiet that's right but I think that what
I'm saying do you do you have do you
have an option because what I was did to
get this from you do you have an option
on your shows to go to the quiet shows
because when I go and I look at you
doing stand-up now it's not very loud
right now you're talking
but other people are kind of more it's
like it's a TED talk I want to snow or
no kind of a library there are there are
moments in my show right where okay so
have you ever heard of have you ever
heard of the factor have you heard of
that so do some that's when you're all
you go okay so there's a moment where
there's a respite okay don't let me know
don't it's like that in the storm so in
this year okay in the storm right into
the tempest yeah no I'll give you a
harbor sometimes I hate you as some [ __ ]
where you just go they've never even
heard that I heard right is that it's
called there's a certain what Brian joke
is I think no I think that there's I've
had a lot of critics who really know the
difference say there is a majesty to his
performance I'm gonna Google those words
in quotes and Bryan Callen and nothing
will come up ISM Majesty but say majesty
but the thing is but the thing is when
most of your comedy show would have that
quote unquote off actor right where's
the laughs right so when I walk into a
room what's up what's up now
what's that little boy what was that
little boy no quiet you quiet
you owe me be quiet wide cuz I should be
in your audience that one was extra that
was a hard slam welcome to Denny's was
not you owe me to 298 that was an
all-american slam no I'm not giving you
tonight can I get you anything else
no listen listen um hey look it's a
picture of Brian in his career so so
what's the deal what what is um what's
it is what another picture oh that's the
chick I thought I'm sorry you know I
thought that would no no I thought that
was a picture there I thought it's
picture you and your career
that's me cheerful is a slippery slope
Chris we're supposed to make this
apologize
that's why give you guys certificates
you guys didn't bring [ __ ] but what are
you growing on your face honestly you
know what I hope oh beard no no it's a
hobo no it's not why wouldn't you shave
just your neck it's politically
incorrect to call the Mahal Bo well I
don't give a [ __ ] cuz you look like a
hobo all the time no you would look like
a junkie no I know that no you know what
I really know in my cult you don't shave
you just let it happen when was the last
time all [ __ ] aside your skin saw
the Sun 2015 come on
what are you tired you if I drew a
[ __ ] picture of your brain coffee
hanging out and with my sidekicks and
chicks and chicks man lazy lazy do all I
think you're a book if we're all books
Eric Chris is a comic yeah is that fair
be well dude Connie look so graphic
novel yeah okay dude I mean the Watchmen
okay my little watchman No am I your
hero what do you think seriously what do
you think you would be the sloth no do
you know what I have a superpower what I
can open up doors without even touching
now at the grocery sure Oh Brian didn't
get the job how do you do that he says I
do it because my fans open the doors for
me dude your fans don't travel with you
around that you've seen that uh you know
what my fans are there they and I'm not
trying to be a dick to you and but no no
listen every time you say that it's dead
no no but let me just explain what my
fans are and it's no big deal and I
don't give a [ __ ] and I don't even want
I didn't want to say this out loud
because I don't care but I'll say it
just for argument's sake let's have a
conversation
so my fans are fans what we would call
fans in life right now hold on it's just
that there's there's cuz I'm always
evolving and always like challenging
argument this guy teaches me teaching
yeah and then you your fans are as we
know and again who cares who cares what
your fans are some are not yet in high
school and others are in high school
right
not real tan credibly fickle so great
they also reveal themselves as babies
they come hell you know in our fan bases
what T fat cake hey would you [ __ ] hey
hey hey Chris butt chin disappeared when
you went like that I'm not yeah I can't
wow you're just no cheer Oh bro bro you
human bird we are uh we are [ __ ]
twenty we are thirty we are 40 or 50 my
god your babies dude what the [ __ ]
why do you pay this because dude [ __ ]
this alpha secretly beta [ __ ] bro I got
it all figured out man I'll do what I
want and it'll be fine and because
you're a buddy everyone's fight oh we're
gonna do [ __ ] you know what I mean no
you're not saying anything you know what
I mean how about this man see what this
man what number one guest on fighter in
the kid
oh dude any people say forget though
okay Will Sasso Michael Rapaport yeah
make way for [ __ ] freak punch you
gotta do that's hey you showed me your
body yesterday pretty damn good right no
I don't think so what okay
did you see the [ __ ] region look at you
I'm great no I'm just got your this I
think imagine what it's like listen you
had the lanky bird look at you you're
you you have I haven't had to fart this
whole time but if I did I would have
done it Wow Chris you have to have more
respect for our space and for this very
amazing part I like the way you're
sitting bro yeah I got I said dude when
I saw a Bon Jovi yeah when I was a kid I
was like that's how I want to sit and I
want to take it up an excellent have you
ever had a sip of alcohol no never a sip
yeah like communion or whatever what a
[ __ ]
so you and you have you ever smoked
nope never see I thought for when I
first met you I was like damn Chris
obviously does drunk yeah Bobby looks
like an alcohol no I just say no cuz
you're a little bit sporadic all the
time yeah I'm not interested in what
they're saying that's why it seems like
that that makes it okay you want coke
I'm like no you're just boring a [ __ ]
yeah we're just boring and I'm thinking
about spaceships or something gonna be
more interesting I'm not on coke be more
interesting how about that that why are
you looking around cuz you're boring and
you're you know what I mean or like you
go to the when you go to the hair caught
place yeah do you say give me the Jimmy
Neutron do you say that word for word
what do you say I want this and then
show them a picture of the back of a
dog's water on my front is that what you
do dude Hey look [ __ ] Ace Ventura son
okay I do
shut up and I'm gonna get I'm gonna get
it I'm gonna get it dude why is it doing
that today I don't like it I tried and
trim it down yesterday and now I'm
feeling a little self don't you touches
so I do space it why do you like this i
straining your hair why do you do like
this like you're felling like you're
picking up because you're watching it's
it's fine dude it's it's fine don't piss
me off caveman you seem really on that
only way is if he attacked you and I
you're useless no no dude I'm not you're
truly useless
I'm free honestly you know what I swear
to god I'm not trying to be a dick you
are as useful as the couch like if the
couch was in the room or Chris is in the
room let me tell you something if I need
a help in fighting Brennan a life in
that location you would you're you're
basically a soft man no but I have a
counterpoint does a couch get hurt what
does a couch get you know what he can do
do you know D kill me and just ignore
you and you dude you to be a simpering
Shh [ __ ] pile in the corner not true
dude hey hey dude I don't rate for $6
lie down and I do it I want that's the
thing hedonistic hedonistic lifestyle
dude I don't give a [ __ ] what you want
me to do I'll sit how I want and I'll do
it anywhere I'll be in court sit like
this I don't get listen sit up or I'm
gonna I'm gonna come out here oh [ __ ]
[Music]
what you tried to kiss me no that's your
you're trying to kiss me
oh that's how you defend yourself I know
I just thought about the people only
listening and not seeing it that you
that's your defense against a
male-on-male attack oh dude you just
alright let's see what else I can't even
York you're going Newland you're trying
to kiss me and your hands are all soft
oh wow that's how you defend your
salary's lotion have some self-respect
and defend yourself got your way God hey
hey hey you should see how he defends
himself watch this no I don't want to
watch me come at him it's not bad see
and that's why are you out of breath row
you got a bum ticker wyden I ran back
what'd you do [ __ ] strength training
he's been running
what are you doing wrestling dude did
you get high up in there man Oh bye-bye
man smoke crack oh no it's awful man I
didn't take dance I know it was a
[ __ ] well tell but you took you took
voice does this answer your question
remember when you and I tried to sing
serious yeah yeah and we started
laughing Brian does that Brian likes to
relive the glory days he doesn't have a
bright future that's not true
you've got a checkered past well that's
[ __ ] true in a bad way I've got kids
I don't know about
and if I find out I'll ignore them
anyway yeah cuz I'm selfish [ __ ]
selfish yeah so it's been 11 on but then
Israel and Lebanon had like that's right
she's not just Israeli she was part of
their Israeli Defense Forces died two
years all women are in Israel it's
mandatory she's a big women and men
she's obviously hey for you no you know
what no what do you say it I'm good man
she wouldn't run you're a bro you're
aces anymore
what are you food be [ __ ] you what
bro not for you hey stand down boy oh
boy Stan hey bro hey no water seed with
caution
nah you know what bro how about this man
I don't even [ __ ] bro I [ __ ] make
sweet love I swear to god man not don't
you think your [ __ ] [ __ ] mail
stuff I push slow and I'm nice about it
man yeah well I don't think I push that
what she's looking for
yeah yeah she is right I'll tell you
that's Wonder Woman I don't want to give
girls what they look for I want to give
girls what they do oh oh in a way I
think the first real athlete thank you -
look dude hey I was talking about
Brendan oh well no because I've got this
trainer and [ __ ]
don't say that don't say thank you
apologize I don't know what you were
saying he's the first he's the first
real athlete 0:02 to actually kind of be
doing stand-up on this level and the
beat well I think the both of us just
like what I think the both of us just
like we zero in on something you are not
gonna you're not an athlete did you ever
do any sports besides you Jitsu blue
belt and stay there
what are these ports what's the one with
the racket with one little rat is like
the rack is that big risk
oh yeah
badminton it's actually up do you know
what I mean you don't even have to say
Sofia Vergara's so shut the [ __ ] up call
him Brennan so sure this guy in Italy
who was I guess Iranian not yeah dude
[ __ ] yeah I respect that [ __ ] now could
you touch your face whatever you want so
don't do that
thank you hundred pounds on you you're
I'm 170 and I'm scrappy as all [ __ ]
get out
don't say I'm starburst and I'll be
honest [ __ ] ask me how I do against
Brennan ask me how I do be honest I do
watch this and let this is how I answer
all my about what like I if I say how
would you do against Brennan in a fight
how would you do against Brennan in a
fight keep busy I don't know what that
means
yeah because he'd be with the police
filling out a report yes hey is he
eating your ass yeah it sounds it's not
a new term like well I say yeah I like
it I like it as a matter of fact it's
the rapper's sometime like cannabis said
I can you know I can't say the n-word
but he says I could eat my ass like you
know it's not it's not a I can't say the
n-word
yeah that's what the lyric bill Morgan
it's nutmeg that's what he says I asked
cat if I was what you thought you cuz
you're a good-looking older like
middle-aged there you go yeah there you
go
and I'm a young buck dude I am me young
you know what I realize 44 no you know
what I realize I'm young dude that's
what I realized no I'm like what the
[ __ ] why do I have Benjamin buttons
disease no I think I got to a certain
point where all of a sudden I started
walking back house dude no cuz your face
I've decided is you have your you that
you're what you indent where your eyes
are so you have an hourglass face which
to me to mean only to me I'm not trying
to be a dick about it okay but if you
look at your face in a vacuum
yeah without your personality right
personality and good hair but just the
face structure yeah is revolting
no way you're saying I got a peanut head
in the worst way and it's it's it's
immoral that you get away with it
ruff yeah don't lose your hair no I'm
gonna I don't like I tell you what I
can't wait to do a [ __ ] role where I
just got to shave this [ __ ] off play
peanut no I mean uh where the [ __ ] is
peanut there he is
and they go like this why are his
shoulders so broad cuz now I get it
right because then I get it now there's
hairs out there I get a lot of months
around hey bring up his Instagram and
he'll say I can't help it
that's all things apply in the man it's
out of nowhere in it and it just out of
nowhere and it was like it it was
literally at like 1:00 in the morning
and it just said I have a swimmer's body
and I go dude and then I just got a
picture of him with a shirt off
well like huh like that well look at him
just keep going I want to see well yeah
there I don't know just keep going like
that cheeky thing that was funny the key
key thing I did it oh yeah there's the
be various and there's computers there
is it so happy with you you get a lot of
a lot of female attention on that
[ __ ] post bro chicks dude don't care
man show me love this right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]